The first high heel ever
was a piece of military footwear.
People in West Asia had been
tremendous horse riders,
and that's how they fought, they rode
in the saddle and they stood up
to shoot their bows and that meant
you need a heel to keep
you in the stirrups, nice and stable.
The Shah of Persia,
he's called Abbas the First,
he sends off some emissaries
into Europe and they turn up
wearing high heels
and everyone goes...
...so suddenly this military clothing
becomes adopted in Europe.
But it's a little bit later on,
in the early 1600s, that we start
to see heels coming in,
and it starts with the blokes,
it's for being manly and butch.
But what happens quite quickly
is women start to emulate
male fashion, and part of that
is they start wearing men's shoes.
The real big moment is when Louis XIV
of France starts wearing heels,
because he's quite a small man,
and he famously has red heels
- that Louboutin mirrored
later on in the 20th Century.
Suddenly everyone at the court
is wearing heels.
Heels go through a bit
of an up and down history
and the 1700s, philosophers are
talking about the rationalism of men,
by contrast, women are said
to be emotional and sentimental
and can't be trusted to do
important things like think.
And so men are being advised
to wear rational shoes
and high heels are not rational.
The 1860s, this is when women's
heels start to become sexy.
We have photography,
a brand new technology,
and quite often
in pornography of this period,
you're seeing women
still wearing their boots,
their shoes with the heels on,
so it becomes erotic.
Hollywood had a huge influence
on the rise of heels as the symbol
of sexiness. In the 1950s,
Marilyn Monroe famously quoted,
I can't think of the exact words
but she said you know...
...she was speaking on behalf of
women. For Monroe, who was about
glamour and beauty and sexiness,
she felt that that was an asset.
People can tell whether women are
wearing high heels without actually
seeing their feet, so it is that
posture, change in the gait.
But a more recent study has shown
that actually it's changing the shape
of the spine that is actually
the attractive thing.
We looked at all the research on
high heels and they are not healthy,
there was increased risk of
musculoskeletal conditions,
bunions and pain.
I think they're too iconic and too
much a part of aesthetics and imagery
and history and power
and sex to ever go away,
and I think they'll always be there.
I'd rather go through quite a lot of
pain and wear them and look nice,
and suffer for it, I think.
I'm crazy about fashion,
I think we all are.
And I think any smart woman
would go on wearing them,
irrespective of what
the consequences are.
Thanks for watching. Don't forget to subscribe and click the bell to receive notifications for new videos.
See you again soon!